the new Game of Thrones Season 8 teaser
shows the crypts of Winterfell where
thousands of years of dead Starks are
entombed Jon Snow carries a torch
through the darkness which fits the
imagery of azor Ahai a hero prophesied
to defeat the darkness with a sword
called light bringer john passes the
tomb of Lyanna stark and john doesn't
know it but Lyanna is his mother she
fell in love with Rhaegar Targaryen but
she died giving birth to Jon lianna's
brother Ned promised to protect Jon by
saying that jon is his child her feather
falls from Liana's statue it was put
there in season one by King Robert who
had loved Liana in season 5 Sansa finds
this feather and talks about how Rhaegar
supposedly kidnapped and raped Liana
which we now know isn't true maybe this
feather represents the truth of Liana
and Rhaegar love and of John's real
heritage Sansa sees the tomb of her
mother Catelyn in the books cat is
resurrected as a zombie called
Stoneheart
so it's funny to see cat as a statue
made of stone we hear a lion from season
3 when Catelyn said she'd once made a
promise to love John that Catelyn found
she couldn't love John because she
thought he was Ned's bastard can't felt
that this broken promise caused all the
horror that comes to House Stark
so this is a reminder of how the stark
family has suffered and of the pain
caused by the secret of John's birth
John sees the tomb of Ned Stark we hear
a lion from season 1 when Ned says that
John may be a bastard but he still Ned's
blood which is true in that Ned is
John's uncle Ned promises that next time
he sees John they'll talk about his
mother so these three voiceover lines
all refer to promises made about John
Ned's promise to protect John cat's
promise to love John and Ned's promise
to talk about John's mum of course
tragically Ned dies and Jon Snow still
knows nothing so when will John find out
about his parents
there are hints in the books that John
will learn the truth in the crypts John
has dreams of the crypts where the
statue's say you are no Stark and there
are rumors of a dragon in the crypts
which might be a metaphor for John
finding his Targaryen dragon identity
there in the show John might just
learned the truth from Sam or bran but
either way how will John react to
learning that he's not Ned's bastard
that his real name is Aegon that he's
the heir to the throne will he start
acting like a Targaryen riding dragons
boning enemies marrying aunts but will
John stay true to his stock identity
Rhaegar is John's father but Ned is the
man who raised him John upholds Ned's
legacy and values like Ned says John is
a stark so just like Theon can be a
Greyjoy and a stark Jon can be a stark
and a Targaryen John Sansa and I assay
statues of themselves representing their
deaths cold fog rolls in representing
the White Walkers and the army of the
Dead the fallen feather freezes which
might mean the death of life on Westeros
so likely Anna and cat and Ned before
them will John Sansa and iodide this
season they're all stronger than they've
ever been
John a heroic King Sansa or a political
player I or a faceless assassin but all
men must die and this is the end of Game
of Thrones by the way it is weird that
bran isn't in this trailer he's the only
living Stark not included maybe it's
because bran has lost his identity by
becoming the three-eyed Raven will bran
find himself again or will he become a
tree man like the last Raven this
trailer is about stark identity John's
parentage and the deathly threat of the
White Walkers but we can go deeper into
the crypts they are vast and dark and
ancient there are lots of theories on
what secrets lie within in the books the
crypts statues are often described as
watching and listening sometimes they
seem to stir as if the dead were
amazing fans speculated that the dead
Starks might rise to fight for
Winterfell like the dead in the Lord of
the Rings or maybe they'll fight for the
White Walkers cuz fans speculated the
Starks are descended from the White
Walkers and the night's king
maybe the Nights Queen is imprisoned
deep in the crypts and the White Walkers
are coming to rescue her
or maybe the great other the god of the
White Walkers is down there and
Winterfell was built to contain him
reyga's harp could be down there or the
Horn of winter or hot pies secret herbs
and spices they wrote lots of
possibilities but this stuff is more in
the books than the show so it will cover
the crypts in another video and comment
below what you want to know about the
crypts Starks and Winterfell and please
like and subscribe
artwork is by Orianna Weisner ray
Laverne and a touch alternates who
locate predicted this whole trailer
thanks to the patrons who support alt
shift X including Peter Alex Trisha
Hopkins McKay Leo cranek Sally Sheehy
Ross M G Joshua Hillier Daniel Larson
infinite and Rookwood Cheers
you